hi my name is Samuel Leeds and in this
video I want to talk to you about how to
get motivated sellers direct without
having to go through an agent whilst
estate agents do have their place and I
love estate agents and I'm actively
buying from estate agents and when they
know you now will bring you the best
kind of deals but sometimes it can be a
bit easier certainly to begin with to go
direct to a motivated seller and
sometimes you get the best deals that
way so here are the five top ways to buy
properties direct to vendor so number
one is Facebook I get a lot of people
messaging me on Facebook saying I'm
selling my house or my friend or my
brother is selling their house and I get
a lot of good deals that way then you
can advertise on Facebook but well I
think the best way is is to just join
facebook groups in your local area join
the Facebook groups let people know that
your property investor put yourself out
there get into conversations social
media is an absolute beast and you can
talk to people like you've never been
able to do in history so use it utilize
it and find motivated sellers online
number two is notice boards a lot of
shop sometimes they are like a
mainstream shop sometimes little off
licenses but they have little notice
boards where you can advertise things
and put things sometimes it's free since
I have to pay a pound or something but
in your local area or in your patch if
you just go into these shops and just
put little post-it notes on the notice
boards and just say something like I'm
looking to buy houses in this postcode
if you're looking to sell give me a call
on you'll be really surprised at the
response rate you can get and you'll get
motivated sellers phoning you instead of
you having to chase estate agents number
three is leaflet drops now if you've got
a particular area or a patch where
you're looking to buy properties maybe
there's certain streets and houses even
particularly then you can pay people
around about thirty pounds to deliver
1,000 leaflets so you can literally just
bombard all the houses in your area with
leaflets which again will say something
similar like I'm looking to buy houses
in this area
please give me a call if you're
interested in selling and again you're
gonna get people phoning you who want to
sell their house motivated sellers
direct with no agent this is something
that I've done a lot in the past and
typically if you do this right you can
get some really really good deals you
can also with leaflets instead of
handing them out on mass or paying
someone to send out thousands keep them
in your car and every time you see a
house that looks like it needs a little
bit of work or it's a bit derelict or if
you see a property that's got to as
state agency boards and you've noticed
it's been on a little while just walk up
and pop it through the letterbox but the
leaflets are a really really good way to
get motivated sellers coming direct to
you number four networking
now when I say networking I have been
talking about in just everyday life
networking but also there are formal
specific networking events that go on
all over the UK every single day
there are breakfasts there are dinners
where business people meet and say how
can we help you in your business now
when I started out at 17 years old I
joined all these networking events not
just property networking events just
business events turned up and would say
I'm looking to buy properties that are
bargain prices and discounted if you
know you want this motivated that's
selling their property I'd love you to
let me know what happen is all of these
business people will then actively be
looking for deals for you and you'll be
looking for deals for them and you just
helped one know that way getting into a
good networking group for me was
absolutely transformational with my
business it's also good because you'll
learn a lot about business as well so I
know it's a bit daunting for some people
like oh my gosh just walking up to a
networking event but just do it get
yourself uncomfortable because if you're
not being uncomfortable and you're not
stretching then you're not growing and
you're dying so get down to a networking
event my challenge is to book on today
to a networking event for next week
number five lastly and this is to be
honest my favorite and probably the
easiest is there are online sites where
you can literally find motivated sellers
direct with their telephone number on
their sites like Gumtree calm open rent
Cote UK it's like right move and
you see a lists of all these houses but
instead of the agents number
there's the vendors number the motivated
sellers number direct where you can
phone them up no agent and get a deal
direct so I hope that video has been
helpful whenever we publish these videos
mentoring Monday videos at 7 p.m. for
the first hour I am on they're
responding to everyone's comments and
questions so please do put your
questions in your comments below I've
read every single one of them and I'll
do my best to comment back as well
thanks so much I'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]